I want to pull up this video we have
this video Ian miles Chong posted it
says this is what's popular on Tick Tock
meanwhile in China kids are learning
about theoretical physics practical
Woodworking and astronomy on doyan which
is their their their version of right
yeah this video is disturbing it's on
par with the NPC girls you guys have
seen that stuff where there's like ice
cream so I just saw it the other day and
I was so confused by it my wife and we
watched it like seven times and we're
sitting there going to bed and we're
watching it over and over again I'm like
what are they doing and by the end you
and everyone else
I won't let myself watch I want to play
this video I got to play this video it's
23 seconds and you'll get a general idea
I don't want to be too loud but here we
go
oh you want to hit the audio
for those that are just listening it is
a guy who's crying and screaming and
trying to stack uh nuts like uh Hardware
nuts or something yeah I don't know I
don't think those are lug nuts
necessarily just Hardware nuts and uh
it's deranged yeah it is absolutely
deranged content I feel it roll for a
second longer he makes this weird like
yeah that's why he's popular is that
face and that sound and stuff so this is
what's possessed this is what kids are
watching you feel your mind disorganized
as you watch it this is what so uh I'll
throw it back to you guys are you guys
familiar with Elsa gate
YouTube started promoting a whole bunch
of these videos of Elsa Spider-Man and
the Joker running around doing
Shenanigans it started devolving into
extremely psychotic content where there
were cartoons of children drinking out
of urinals and consuming feces like 2013
or something this is the algorithm at
the time
I think this was YouTube it was an
accident yeah YouTube just had an
algorithm that recommended what got
clicked the most they didn't really
think about it and it was being
exploited and people were just doing
keyword searches and then making
whatever was getting the most clicks and
it turned into this nightmare scenario I
think with Tick Tock you look at this
video pull this clip back up so people I
want people who are watching to see this
guy's face
Tick Tock is promoting this stuff
because I think they figured out hey
Elsa gate is destroying the fabric of
the United States and the West because
the children who watch that are going to
have psychological problems and Trauma
later in life this is very much the same
thing as are the NPC girls there are
already stories about uh first young
girls facing extreme depression because
of Instagram but now you have stories of
young girls developing Tourette's
Syndrome because they would watch a
popular influencer with Tourette's start
imitating the person and then start
developing involuntary ticks in their
communication style because this is
Social Development for young people
I think Tick-Tock is my personal opinion
promotes this stuff in the algorithm
because it is gutting and destroying the
fabric of our of our young people this
is another reason why I think it's so
extremely important one you guys share
tell your friends to go see movies like
sound of freedom but all the other stuff
that that angel Studios has coming out
you've got uh what's that new there's
another movie you've got coming out
you've got Cabrini Cabrini yes I think
the shift is coming out in December it
looks really good there's a there's a
there's one coming out in October called
after death oh cool dude
yeah the looks good this is awesome
I really want to see Cabrini that
trailer looks really amazing John
Lithgow is in it yes yeah and it's the
same director as son of Freedom it's
Alejandro oh that's wonderful and it's
his best workout it looks really my wife
my wife and I screened it and my wife
came away and she said top five movie of
all time for me wow my daughters that's
their favorite movie too wow that's
amazing yeah you know uh once once we
have screeners we'll let you right on
right but but I don't wanna I don't want
to watch a screener I watch in theaters
that's right yeah okay yeah all right
yeah so like get you in the theater when
it's time I don't I don't know if it's
supposed to be a secret ever what sound
of Freedom you know someone reached out
to me and said like hey we got a
screener we want you to see the film I
was like I'm going to theaters man I
like I like you but it's so much better
yeah but that's the theaters the
experience yeah especially there with
your friends and afterwards we're
walking out we're talking about the
parts we liked and not just that the
theater is this it's a it's a communal
experience you everybody goes in there
there's you guys know who Andrew
Peterson is who wrote The Wing feather
Saga uh amazing author from Nashville
musician pretty pretty big name but he
uh he he has a Blog called the rabbit
room and on that blog they published
it's a group of people that write on it
they wrote a blog post called the
sacrament of Cinema
and in it explains and this is what
shifted my gears on why movie theaters
are hanging on and why I think that they
have a bright future
is
he compares the the sacrament when you
go to church and you let go of
everything and you get into the exact
same experiences everybody around you
and you focus on this one thing which
represents Jesus Christ and you focus
focus focus and you you you take the
sacrament when you go to the theater
you're surrendering all your screens all
the social media and you're allowing
yourself to be enveloped in an
experience so that director built for
you and crafted for you
and then immerse yourself and there's no
pause button and you're all together and
so you have this incredible experience
and it can be it can be life-changing
and I think that people are hungry to
get away from the social screens
and that the easiest most simple way to
do that is to head to the cinema and
shut it all down shut everything down
and it's healthy for us right now
where we're over stimulated so it almost
sounds weird because it used to be the
stimulation spot but this is actually I
think it's a way to shut things off I do
too the good news is so when we look at
this video and this guy is screeching
and making nonsense content which is
going to traumatize kids they're going
to grow up and they will imitate are
they going to be building spaceships are
they going to be astronauts are they
going to be even race car drivers no
they're going to be saying insane things
or acting like NPCs and saying ice cream
so good but we're winning one obviously
you guys are here we're talking about
angel Studios all the projects you have
but along with this story is Dylan
Mulvaney announcing a stepping back from
producing content because only 50 of
Americans like me Dylan says and so
Mulvaney will be slowing down content
this is what happens when people speak
up for what they believe in when they
say uh rather sternly but politely don't
Mulvaney has bad content which is bad
for kids promoting alcohol to kids you
know people want to talk about gender
ideology I'm like absolutely but also
this the the Scandal starts with Dylan
promoting booze to children on Tick Tock
like let's that was the whole thing
grabbing all the beer cans cracking them
open and being like March Madness drink
beer and the average audience of tick
tock is under 21. these these are not
good things so when we see this stuff we
complain about Tick Tock yes there are
issues with a lot of people using the
platform Tick Tock banned us for
instance for no reason little sour
grapes there I suppose for no reason we
were moved we can't even express our
opinions but I think this is what leads
me to believe ultimately they're trying
to influence young people in ways that
destroy their lives when we look at
sound of Freedom when we look at I mean
Angel Studios you guys are slaying it as
it's crazy the expansive growth
we may not have control of all the
institutions I have people say how can
you claim we're winning if Hollywood is
owned by the left if television is on by
the left I'm like theaters one of my
points was theaters are not owned by the
left but my what I'm saying is uh
winning doesn't mean owning everything
winning doesn't mean you won right
winning means you are gaining the
territory in the conflict that's right
and we are winning
that's right what you said about the
theater is so true it's it's epically
true it's been true for thousands of
years Beyond like Cinema's relatively
new aspect of theater but the theater
since the Greeks
it's a local thing it's not a global
thing people vibrate together in the
local community that's the ticket I had
a dude when I saw sound of freedom on my
to my left it was like breathing super
heavy he wasn't very healthy I was
drinking his diet coke or whatever he's
drinking and but it like I have love for
that man it made that experience like
unique it was it was in my ear and it
was a little distracting but at the same
time I'll never forget it I'll remember
that forever that moment and I love that
guy I just remember that guy it was cool
to be there with them or or the fact
that I think it's it's I mean we might
be seeing as much as 10 of showings of
sound of Freedom having standing
ovations
there's showings where people complete
strange strangers hug each other yes and
this isn't an uncommon report I think
also you can't have that at home yeah
since covid has basically died down the
madness around covet people want to go
out and socialize again and the cinema
is the place yes
I'll say yeah I gotta say it every time
like the first the intro of of sound of
freedom is just so good oh yeah man it's
it's remarkable to me that they walked
away from that that they're like how do
you how do you not watch that and be
like wow this is an amazing film yeah
it's the intro just the intro man yeah
really well done we had a super chat
from earlier someone suggested that you
guys do or somebody does a movie about
the Statue of Liberty that story about
the Statue of Liberty that would be
really fun that'd be cool we are working
right now probably the first piece of it
will be done next year Jordan should be
talking about this part Founders yeah
yeah we're building a series on the
founding of America and trying to build
an entire this is so under control yes
this is so undertone old Game of Thrones
with Memorial Compass but yeah of course
but this is such an undertold story
think about how many movies you know the
Patriot and you know like a bazillion
documentaries dude the Patriot is like
John's favorite movies of all time the
Patriot is such a good yeah John Adams
in The Patriot that's about you know
that and there's that music only 1776
that was pretty good in the UK they
complained but there's another depiction
of the British and The Patriot
because you get the bad guy like killing
children and they're like oh how dare
you it's not anti-british
what I mean like go out there and make
your own Pro British movie I think
I think I I watched Patriot probably way
after everyone else but after it you're
like yeah let's hang an American flag
like this is great like you I I feel
like there is something really positive
out of walking out of theater and being
like I feel empowered to do something I
think sound of Freedom has that effect
for a lot of people even just be more
conscious of how they can serve their
local community but like the Patriot
makes you want to be like yeah it's a
good country this is cool stuff like
yeah I think that is sort of uh along
with the moral hunger and Society some
some way to feed that because videos
like this Tick Tock of this guy
screaming like that's the equivalent of
like fake chemical sugar that we're
feeding to our young people you need to
give them more substantial content for
them to to feed their minds their
emotions their souls things like that if
you have them on the app where there's
nothing nutritious so to speak there
then of course they wither away
the stuff's junk food you know what that
is really interesting you bring up the
Patriot and that was made by an
immigrant right uh Alejandro is an
immigrant Frank Capra who made a ton of
Americana right that uh It's a Wonderful
Life and um uh Mr Smith Goes to
Washington all these films that helped
Define our country made by immigrants
and um so that's what I love about
um the cinema is that it's all about
uniting around an idea rather than
partisanship or or country lines it's
just about uniting around an idea well
and I think it's interesting too because
this new study came out saying they're
like only 18 percent of Americans
consider themselves like very patriotic
which is sort of strange but when we saw
periods and no one quote me on the data
here but when we saw periods of high
patriotism it's when we're in Conflict
when we have to pull together with
people that we don't know who live in
our country we feel bonded that way and
to your point like I think at least in
my experience like a first generation
American immigrants choose to be here
and they realize often why they have
they have a decision there's a choice
right there's sort of an act of love in
that choice and I think that in some way
makes it easier to be clear about what
you have when you're born into something
it sometimes becomes easy to be like
math not that great because you don't
have anything to compare it to right
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time